it's always fun to have you I'm pumped
up Wiggins Mori I met more like 10 years
ago I went to a show you mean you met
him I'm well yeah I have a picture with
him I was trying to look for it on my
Instagram but I can't find it but he's a
nice guy and it's I say Maury Povich
what's the right way Povich okay all I
was saying Paul I said as I say Povich I
think it's at our vision Hobbit which is
the right way I just say he's a guy you
can ask how do you say your name that we
we should all know this and I feel like
you could just go with Maury and
everybody knows who it is
there's no other Tuesdays with choose
right Tuesdays with Maurey yeah I I've
read that book and like got something
same samesies I was like oh I'm gonna
start like forgiving every well when I
was in physical therapy school like we
had to learn about ALS and I like
couldn't come I couldn't study and focus
on it so I just like I'll read Tuesdays
with Maurey because he had and I felt
like no no I mean it's a graduate
program and I was like I'm just gonna
read this novel
[Music]
the studio everyone I told you he was
gonna drop by it was gonna happen quick
all right nice to meet you
see you it's so many people no seven
beep everybody everyone's so excited
about you when I talk about you yes
people glow they they have a story they
have a relationship with you and I
learned last night from doing some
research that your you were the Current
Affair guy
of course yeah I mean of course but I
was a child when that show was on so I
didn't like you you actually watched it
my mom watch it and I loved it it gave
me an appreciation for really yes
kachunk I don't remember all of it but I
forgot that that was you and then you
became Maury Povich I loved that show
that show first of all the kachunk you
know that the sound came from we always
said when we started the show we wanted
to have something like the 60 minutes
clock so that if you heard it oh it's on
you know so they put a the old-time
elementary school construction paper
cutters the sound of a construction
paper cutter put with the swish of a
golf club put through a synthesizer and
that was named after my wife
the kachunk on top of each other it
makes sense was like in the day like 86
so it was there the first days of
synthesizing and so that's that's what
they use it worked I remember it it's
still yeah there was always something my
mom had on your mom still has my show I
mean in this room they know what both my
producer and Chris de Stefano have you
been doing live taping I have not but
I'm going tomorrow they're 10 years ago
it was awesome yeah it's really this is
the tourist thing to do when you come to
New York going to the live the live
taping of my show is as good Internet
entertainment as you would ever want my
live audience makes the show I mean yes
the heartbeat of the show because they
go crazy because in my episode when we
found out it was the father we won it
was because before we were like there's
no line there was in line there
were people of in the episode that I was
at the family of one of the guys on the
show and they were like he's I know he's
the father I know you know nobody knows
anything I was with my friends like no
he's not no it's not we have no we have
no frame of reference then when he was
like we were just like I told you it was
great vivid memories these people are
conjuring just from being at you're so
10 years ago it truly sounds like such a
great life experience to have i I heard
a story of an NFL quarterback this as
many years ago said that the the players
would be in the locker room and they
would not go out to practice until
[Laughter]
O'Neill watches my show every single day
and Shaq said and what he does is he
calls up all his friends and they bet on
who the father no I wanted to give you a
second to tell Maury what you he means
to you was you went to a taping yeah so
I took a TV production class in high
school this is like 15 years ago and I
went to a live taping of your show and
that's when I knew that I had to work in
production I was watching your stage
manager and I was just like mesmerized
like what is that job I want to do
something like that
really yeah that's when you got the the
itch yeah production ever since the show
yes yeah how's it going
it's so fun how do you how do you I'm
guessing people are having fun working
on your show how have you well it's it's
the most amazing part about that is that
my producers my associate producers my
cameraman have been there for 15 20
years they people like the atmosphere
the the way we work they were work
environment I have I started the first
talk show I did was prepare a mountain
that was like 28 years ago and I still
have five people throughout my staff who
have been with me 28 years I mean I I
mean I've got as they say you sent my
kids through school now they've got kids
I mean now those kids are ready to go to
school but it starts at the top I mean
people who enjoy it starts with you and
that just credit to you but I always I
always look it's this business is I mean
I've seen so much in the television
radio business in my life that it's easy
to pick out the fools
and so the you know the the a-holes show
themselves very early and so therefore
you know exactly what the guard against
yeah so that's that's how I do and as
far as like the suits you know the
executives yeah there's nothing better
to keep distance between you and the
suits than a good rating if you get a
good rating they don't care about the
moment there's a dip well we think that
you ought to do this really where the
hell have you been
I I wanted to ask you about the daily
grind of doing a show so I mean how many
episodes are we talking have you done
between three and four thousand yeah
insane so how many do you tape a week we
tape five a week I tape usually
we tape and Stanford Stanford
Connecticut and we taped three on
Thursdays and two on Fridays we work
about nonono 27 weeks a year do 100 and
I don't know 30 or 40 shows what is it
do you ever reach a point where you're
like okay again like how do you muster
that cuz you never seem bored of it how
do you muster because because I believe
even though for instance between the
lie-detector themes and the DNA themes
that's those are our two signature
themes but since I came out of news many
for many many years I've always believed
in storytelling and I just want to find
even with those two themes all the time
unique qualities of every single story
and so I believe each person each
personality has a unique quality about
them either good or bad that I can bring
out and if I continue to do that I won't
get bored yeah so that's you know that's
my mantra that's really cool and you can
tell that that's why we love this yeah
and the other thing is and I've always
said this about talk shows and I learned
this a long time ago when I first
started it's like being in a in a
campaign to be elected you have to knock
on somebody's door they have to open the
door they have to welcome you in they
have to feel so comfortable with you
that they'll sit you at the table or sit
you on the couch and you have to become
a member of that family and if you are
that if you can do that then you got a
chance of being successful that's
successful that's that's the way I've
looked at it all my life and I've looked
on it as being an advocate for the
audience all that's why for instance I
don't know I've never known the result
of any DNA test or lie-detector test
before I open up the envelope because
you're an advocate for the audience you
know I don't want to know representing
their experience right and I don't want
to know anything more than they do look
if I did then I'd skew the questions in
a certain way that's fascinating because
I've hosted two shows to talk shows like
did it last past two seasons and that I
did feel that there the audience just
didn't
get to know me or didn't trust me enough
there was something there was some
element of that or wasn't given a chance
to whatever it was but you're really
tapping into something as as a host
trying to approach the job like you're
their advocate no question it's oh it's
a really cool approach and it's that's
why it's worth and yet you can bring out
your own vulnerabilities yes I mean you
you bring out your own experiences I
mean for instance I mean I can't tell
you how many times I've told various
fathers for instance who are raising a
child that is not theirs and whether
they will continue to raise that child I
keep saying look my wife and I have a
child in our family and I I'm not the
birth father of that child and he is as
close to me as my birth children that
there's no difference and you so you
have to be able to unload yourself yes
to the guests and the viewers that is
extremely compassionate and like and
makes them that's great that you share
that experience and I another thing is
that look there is nothing in my life
that comes close to the experiences that
my guests go through I never lived those
experiences but there's some connective
human instinct that they feel safe in my
company or on my show you're drunk for
sure but I still man I'm just feel good
my blood pressure's low right now I I'm
not sweating my heart's not pop I don't
pass out good I just feel calm I'm gonna
get somebody pregnant tonight cool all
right great
[Laughter]
[Music]
you